[Music]
in the picture of NSYNC in the Britney
biopic I have it's interesting casting
choices there did they get it right they
actually look a little more like the
Backstreet Boys because a couple of more
like Howie D
I have no idea I'm not worried because
I'm not Britney adjusting no I mean look
it's obviously gonna be some kind of you
know love story you know about them I'm
sure they're not happy about it at all
but hey yeah it's supposed to be fun I'm
sure of course I'll watch it come on I
get to see a little meal in there why
not
what are you oh Michael doing for the
holidays I'm gonna go visit my family
Mississippi then we go visit his family
in Miami and then we're gonna take a
little vacation to Spain I read that you
guys are wanting to start a family how's
that going has any progression there's
no way you know we're gonna start the
process in spring so we have a little
time and yeah we're gonna go through a
surrogacy to have our first babies and
then hopefully adopt after that to see
if the first ones did not drive us crazy
but yeah we're excited to expand daddy
it's Baskin I mean I think I'll be a fun
dad I grew up in the south with some
really good morals so they you know I
will be kind of a stricter dad than I
think my husband you'll be the bad cop
I'll be the bad cop he'll be don't walk
all over him but yeah I like to put
little rules of place you want it to be
a boy or a girl or you know yeah I think
he wants a girl I mean because he just
yeah he's always talking about a little
girl named so I think he's really
pushing for the girl but I'm happy with
whatever
[Music]